all right welcome and good evening what
a night we have ahead of us we are on
the eve on the eve of the South Carolina
primary we have a Bernie rally going on
tonight we have a trump rally going on
tonight we are going to be dipping in
and out from both of them I am back on
Twitch as many of you know I got banned
Tuesday night by what we now know are
completely fraudulent copyright
claimants it has been a fiasco lawyers
are involved twitch is involved it's
been completely crazy but we are back
because the claims were fraudulent and
that's a whole other story I'm not going
to get too much into that today because
there is just so much else to discuss
now the one thing I I don't yet have a
plan for where I can pick up the Bernie
rally stream I found a trump rally
stream I've been searching for a Bernie
rally stream you know searching of
course only under live things and I'm
only seeing Trump rallies live so we
need this is the the Bernie rally in
Springfield Massachusetts very close to
here and my own stream is coming up
interestingly in the search results but
no others so if somebody could direct me
to where we can we can find the Bernie
stream also scheduled to start right
around 7:30 then let me know because I
just don't I just don't know where it is
going to be a the next four days could
be the most consequential four days so
far of the 2020 election in the sense
that we will have the South Carolina
primary which is sort of duo do-or-die
for Joe Biden and then we have Super
Tuesday and Dan Tom Steyer by the way
South Carolina and then we have Super
Tuesday where it will be clear is is
this thing going likely to a contested
negotiated or brokered convention or is
Bernie going to be able to get 50% plus
one unless something radically changes
on Super Tuesday unlikely anybody else
could get to 50% plus one the two most
likely outcomes are either you know a
contested stew 50% plus one or Bernie
does
let's see Bernie usually streams his
rallies on Twitter and Facebook okay if
it I checked that if anybody at some
point has a specific plan for where to
grab the Bernie rally please do let me
know I will of course be taking your
questions and comments if you're
watching on YouTube via super chat
they'll show up in the lower right it's
so depressing that we have this message
right now that says no new super chats
or members but I'm confident that that
will change I think people are going to
start with the super chats at some point
I do want to say thanks on twitch to
Stefon row who has subscribed for four
months with twitch prime and Shane errs
who has gifted a subscription very much
appreciate that thank you very very much
we will also have a I'm it's a I don't
usually do like random Friday night
rally streams so I'm doing just a small
twenty five new member target for
tonight and we'll see if we can do
anything with that there is a coupon
code that'll save you sixty six percent
so we're standing by for Trump and we
are standing by for Bernie Sanders
although I don't actually have a Bernie
Sanders rally available here let me see
if I can do Bernie Sanders Twitter I
just looked and didn't see any any live
stream there we can check the Facebook
one seeing videos of people marching
Bernie Sanders Facebook it'd be ideal if
it was on YouTube just so I don't have
to the sizing of the video might not
work quite right if we're switching back
and forth between a YouTube and a
Facebook stream not seeing anything on
Bernie's Facebook page either so I'm
gonna need you guys to help me out with
that and where where we can find the
Bernie livestream on on YouTube let me
do another search here Bernie Sanders
rally and then we will of course filter
by live and yes still not seeing
anything unfortunately very very
unfortunate so anyway maybe be a super
chat is the easiest way to get the
message
me about where to pick up that rally a
lot of people I see are asking by how
much do I believe Joe Biden is going to
win in South Carolina tomorrow I have
said let me actually pull up the polling
numbers I have said that I do believe
Joe Biden whoa Joe Biden is going to win
South Carolina let's see here
South Carolina numbers Biden right now
winning by 16 oh we can't even see that
actually hold on 1621 nine for I believe
Biden so there are people who are
conservatively estimating that Biden is
gonna win by four to five I actually
think Biden's gonna win more like by
eight or eight or ten or even more than
that but we will see we will see let me
say thank you to the Mike Lennon who has
subscribed for five months in a row with
twitch Prime Mike says love the show
David as always twitch subscriptions and
your messages show up in the vertical
blue box in the upper right and super
chats on YouTube show up in the lower
left none so far none so far which is
which is very very depressing I see that
there see are we dealing with trolls
guys it seems that people on YouTube are
complaining that there are people
trolling as I've said before political
disagreements are fine trumpets are
welcome and that that's I'm not worried
about that but we don't do we don't
allow personal attacks and we don't
allow you know a lot of we don't allow
hate speech anti-semitism racism or at
racism even any of that stuff you will
get banned and the moderators have been
fully fully deputized I am thinking you
know we've been doing a lot of
coronavirus coverage I have been
thinking of getting a mask and doing the
show with a mask not one of those cheap
paper masks but actually getting like a
proper double filter respirator mask and
even possibly reflective goggles and
doing the show that way I think visually
it would be compelling and the concern
is that the microphone would not
properly pick up my my audio but I think
that would be a really good $50
investment
I'm talking about the heavy-duty masks
you would use like you're working with
asbestos for example or something like
that I do want to show you one video
which let's see I actually asked Erin
Rupert to find this for us earlier today
this is really wacky stuff a a guy went
on fox news and he was supposedly
cleared of coronavirus but he couldn't
stop coughing
hopefully doctors and scientists will
get a better better handle on the whole
situation fortunately from what I
understand you know it is contagious but
the death rate is is pretty low so hang
on his daughter yeah I understand the
fear yeah we can see so cough what do
the doctors say about your own condition
moving forward as we wrap this up and
then he takes so now he's drinking out
of the water bottle obviously something
now she's I'm fine
I got tested twice negative both times
the cough probably just as anyway so
it's just like come on you know the
visual aspect of this is not good all
right we have Trump coming out now and
we got to keep it down because if the
audio gets picked up YouTube will do
horrible horrible things to me so we're
gonna get that in a second we're gonna
try to find the Bernie rally as well
super chats coming in thanks to Peter
Lee for the super chat ash daddy says
David what will it take for Trump
sycophants to see how bad he is at his
job they won't I mean just forget about
it forget the you defeating Trump in
November can't have anything to do with
reliance on convincing Trump is to vote
for somebody else it just it can't can't
because they're not going to change
their mind and it's not it's not even
worth worth trying let me say thank you
to VTEC viselli who is new member number
one today we have a very modest goal of
just 25 new website members and VTech is
new member number one today thanks VTech
appreciate that I am still looking for a
good stream of the Bernie
rally which is scheduled to start at the
bottom of the hour if anybody has any
idea on that please let me know I am
still not finding any live streams of
the Bernie Sanders rally and if anybody
can super chat me or somehow make a make
make the URL known I would love to find
good video of that let me also say thank
you to dr. NEX for the twitch prime sub
god-emperor Trump one two three four for
the twitch prime sub and paradigm shift
for the twitch prime subs much
appreciated and let's see what Trump has
to say here oh no we still got music I
have to be really careful with that
music
let's see yeah I know I thought that
Bernie did stream on his YouTube channel
but for whatever reason I'm not seeing
any events they're scheduled or active
knowledge gizmo says Biden lies about
civil rights involvement shame I'm
covering that on Monday Ash daddy says
oh do you think a 50-pound rabbit is a
big rabbit that strikes me as a large
rabbit I imagine most rabbits or more in
the I don't know like 8 to 12 pound
range although I don't really know that
much about rabbits to be perfectly
honest I'm not seeing anything live on
the Bernie YouTube channel so I don't
it's not looking too good there but
again as soon as somebody gets me a
proper stream for Bernie
we will also follow what's going on
there let's see if the music's down yet
it is it's already good I've got it
maxed out guys by the way it won't go
any louder it's already slurring that's
that's not building that who believed in
faith family God and country thank you
things come from ever cared about until
three years ago hypetrain happening by
the way on the number of people outside
but didn't get if anybody would like to
give up where you're standing or your
seat please raise your hand begin right
thank you all very much oh this is great
no they don't get it you know down the
road they have a rally for to the people
that are gonna be running tomorrow
[Music]
it's right that shouldn't be once and
this is what your life is at this point
so I think they're gonna set up a round
table you know that's what they do they
said so people want to go to a rally
they end up sitting at a round table
talking about the definition of
impeachment I may have a scream with a
louder audio let me just test it
thrilled to be back in the great state
of South Carolina yeah with thousands of
hard-working American patriots who
believe in faith family God and country
thanks a little behind ya maybe we don't
play at the audio player it's a
phenomenal crowd only topped by the
number of people outside but didn't get
if anybody would like to give up where
you're standing or your seat please
raise your head all right then let's
begin right thank you all very much so
this is great no they don't get it
you know down the road they have a rally
for to the people that are gonna be
running tomorrow
[Music]
I see people saying the burning that's
right they're not gonna make it not
seeing it opponent and send me a link
that'd be great so I think they're gonna
set up a roundtable you know that's what
they do they said so people want to go
to a rally they end up sitting at a
round table talking about the definition
of impeachment
crazy
[Applause]
crazy it's a crazy deal no the to fake
news media they've been trying to figure
this out for years they still don't get
it though they don't get it look at all
of those cameras look at all of those
guys that's a lot of cameras too loud
okay let me tell you that that's a lot
of cameras Lindsay and Tim that's a lot
of kid they heard you guys were here
they heard Tim was here and that Lindsay
was here and then nothing liking Lindsay
Graham
and they said we're not going to attend
that rally but you know when we heard
those two guys plus our great
congressman here great congressman but
this is an incredible time for our
nation we're thrilled to be in the midst
of what we call the great American
comeback in this one so we'll dip in in
and out of this I mostly want to hear
from you guys and we know what Trump's
gonna do it's just sort of entered
background entertainment as we wait for
the Bernie rally but keep me posted so
it seems like people are saying the
Bernie rally screen just isn't up yet
because it's still a while until it
starts so let me do a few super chats
and all that stuff thanks to hero shadow
for subscribing on Twitch and thanks to
Robert zero eight three six two for the
twitch crime sub appreciate that over on
YouTube let's see here
Ryan nawicki says New York Times article
interviewed 93 super-delegates and found
a consensus that they would vote Bernie
out in a broken brokered convention
what's your reaction my reaction is yeah
we know we know j DJ 3000 says bernie
rally is on PBS youtube I didn't find
that Michael blanco says David will you
be streaming results tomorrow I have a
possible conflict tomorrow and I don't
know yet I want to do South Carolina's
results tomorrow but I don't know if I'm
gonna be home to do a home stream or
able to get over to the studio so we'll
see we'll see tomorrow Amanda fright
this asking am i attending the Sanders
rally in Boston I am not I just I it
it's the rallies at noon they suggest
getting to the comment at 10:00 I just I
have too much going on and I can't you
know for hours is just crazy in the
crowd
Oh nonsense oh I'll watch it remotely
from the comfort of wherever wherever I
am I think I'll be better off that way
Zachary Monroe hey Zack every time I
hear Trump I feel like my IQ gets lower
and lower keep up the great DP you are
one of the only people that I trust for
news thank you so much
Moses Moses eben Moses says do you have
any thought on Russia Turkey escalation
in idiom not as of yet not as of yet oh
it's time talking about vote counting
now one of my people came up to me and
said mr. president they tried to beat
you on Russia Russia Russia that didn't
work out too well
they couldn't do it they tried the
impeachment hoax that was not a perfect
conversation
that's right anything they tried it over
and over they've been doing it since you
got in its all turning they lost it's
all turning think of it think of it and
this is their new hoax but you know we
did something that's been pretty amazing
yeah you put goggles on when you got
that spray tan a very very amazing Jimmy
big nut says is peace stored in the
balls I would talk to a urologist my
friend but I would google bladder a
retro path access do a live stream with
LA gay classical liberal I don't know
what you're talking about a retro let me
say thank you to gsella for subscribing
for two months with twitch Prime I also
want to say a huge thank you to asthma
and I'd slot who is new member number
two of the evening a very modest goal of
25 new members this evening Esmond is
new member number 2 SJ DJ 3000 says
Trump gets Rudy to Wuhan to dig dirt on
virus yeah that would be an interesting
investigation for Rudy to participate
and go to Wuhan and put corona virus
under physical surveillance the way they
had Murray Ivanovich and see see what
they can come up with there a lot of
people furious with the twitch chat now
it seems some people on twitch are
disgusted with what's happening in the
chat I don't notice anything
particularly vile happening but I I'm
certainly always always curious about
what's going on goes up to a hundred
thousand people a year die and so far we
have lost nobody to coronavirus oh yes
mapping clapping like that has anything
to do with front and it doesn't mean we
won't write that we are totally prepared
it doesn't mean we won't but think of it
you hear 35 and 40,000 people and we've
lost nobody and you wonder the press is
in hysteria mode CNN fake news and the
camera just went off
[Applause]
the camera just went off turn it back on
hey by the way hold it look look at this
and honestly all events are like this
it's about us it's all about us
I wish they'd take the camera show the
arena place
show they never got to meet them who
else
they never do the first
oh my god that line again Brian Campbell
says are you getting a turbo graphics 16
mini next month I don't even know what
that is
let's I'm actually curious is that like
is that some kind of a set a porn thing
or what is a turbo graphics
I'm kidding by the way turbo graphics 16
mini notice the PC engine Mini in Japan
and PC core graphics Mini in Europe is a
dedicated home video game console by
Konami modeled on any C's turbo graphics
16 designed by Hudson soft it emulates
the original 16-bit hardware this is the
first I've heard of it let's see it's
10,000 yen and I don't know exactly what
that trend that's gotta be about a
hundred US dollars I don't know a thing
about it but it sounds compelling Ben
Taylor says hi David hope you were well
and have a good weekend thank you
Thoreau fir Beck says a few bucks to ops
offset all the D monetization stay the
course fight the power thank you so much
I appreciate that
great - great to hear from you great to
see you we are going in and out of
Trump's rally of course it is a trump
rally considered child abuse I'm
thinking of these three gentlemen back
here in particular this one who seems to
it seems as though the rally has been
weaponized against this child's future
that's the sense that I'm getting but
you tell me and make sure to let me know
when the Bernie rally stream comes up
and we will also we want to hear some of
that as well
drats will only say horrible things even
though they know we're doing a great job
we do it a great job with what we have
to work with it you've gotta buy the
democrats want us to fail so badly even
if their actions and you take a look
hurt the people of this country yes so
this is a sick talking point Don junior
started up with this on Fox News saying
Democrats want hundreds of millions of
Americans to die merely to make Trump
look bad on coronavirus I don't want the
stock market crashing you should see
what's going on in my mutual fund
account I don't want a single person to
die from coronavirus I have some
projects coming up that I don't want to
see canceled because they involve a lot
of travel including maybe to your city
imagine that and I don't want to be
dealing and constantly worried about
coronavirus and
and the idea that they are using now
spreading that the left wants the stock
market to crash and wants people to die
so that Trump loses no no that's
disgusting and even suggesting it shows
how far we fallen
only in South Carolina can you say Oh
you're gonna get us in trouble no I'm
just repeating what he said for the fake
snooze I'm just no but seriously you
know the Academy Awards has gone way way
down in ratings you know why because
they started attacking us and we don't
believe in it anymore
that's not why there's just so many
options I haven't watched the Oscars in
probably 10 or 12 years or something
like that Scott Phillips says have you
resolved your recent twitch copyright
strike situation yet are you worried it
has been resolved the twitch copyright
strike we got on Tuesday night during
the debate stream was fraudulent from
people who did not actually have the
authority to strike us or any of the
other people that they struck and struck
like Peter struck you know Trump likes
to talk about him and it has been
removed and we are investigating further
possible action at this point in time
but we did hit a bit of a really GLE
roadblock in that the registrar for the
website that was sort of put up half
Hazzard Lee to look like the real
website of the claimant the Registrar
won't tell us
IP address info or anything like that so
we'd likely you know it would be quite
expensive legally to really go through
the entire thing but we are
investigating we are certainly certainly
investigating let me say a huge or huge
thank you to Jeff Thompson Jeff Thompson
is new member number three tonight we do
have a very modest goal of 25 new
members at join pakman.com we're at 3
you can get a 66% discount can you
imagine it's Friday at the studio no
one's here but me so there was nobody
here to stop me from doing the 66
percent discount coupon code 2020 now
something weird seems to be going on
with a video here seems to be kind of a
weird frame rate a virus starts in China
bleeds its way into various countries
all around the world
please doesn't spread widely at all in
the United States because of the early
actions that myself and my
administration took lie against a lot of
other wishes
and the Democrats single toy talking
point and you see it is that it's Donald
Trump's fault right miss Donovan
now just things that happen but you know
what this does show you things happen
whoever thought of this two weeks ago
would have thought this could be going
on for weeks ago you wouldn't but things
we've been talking about it for months I
mean honestly what on earth is this guy
talking about two weeks ago who could
have thought that this would be going on
now it would it had that shows you what
kind of a fantasy world this guy is
regularly living in Zachary Monroe oh
wait you'll see
Eddie xkey says Bernie rally starts in
10 minutes great if do we have I'm
checking the Bernie YouTube channel and
I don't see oh okay we now have very
good so let's get that up Bernie's
YouTube channel has gone live and very
very nice okay so let me actually get
set up properly here I want to get the
right all of the right things here so
we've got that just excuse me one moment
folks uh don't adjust your television
everything is working fine and then
we've got the Bernie rally there we go
so I'm going to keep the volume up here
just so we can we'll hear it
when it goes live and Springfield
Massachusetts perfect the old stomping
grounds of the David Pakman show by the
way
Zachary Monroe says do you think it's
possible for birdie to win any
conservative states Texas Alabama
Louisiana probably not no I don't think
so I actually I don't think any Democrat
is gonna win most of those states and
it's really going to ultimately come
down to Pennsylvania Ohio Wisconsin
North Carolina Florida will be important
that the normal states are going to be
the important ones if Bernie wins
Alabama or Texas it's going to be such a
landslide that it won't even matter that
he won those states because it will mean
that the entire thing has gone
historically against Donald Trump
dillinger sciatic says will replacing
mad
with CAG Keep America great be a
political liability also who should or
shouldn't drop out after South Carolina
well we have to see the results to know
who should drop out after South Carolina
it's probably going to mean I mean
listen Tulsi still doesn't have a path
to a single delegate she should be gone
if steyr doesn't get some delegates he
should drop otherwise I don't think
anybody else really would be
well-advised to drop before Super
Tuesday you might as well stay in let me
say thank you over on Twitch where it's
been quiet on Twitch but I want to say
thank you to K math 95 K math 95 has
subscribed with twitch Prime I very much
appreciate that I also want to say thank
you to a very special person this
evening Bethany Hudgens Beth
that was odd Bethenny Hudgens is new
member now everything going wrong today
you remember number four Thank You
Bethenny I appreciate that four of 25 at
join pakman.com for people asking
whether I will be live with results
tomorrow I don't know yet
I don't know yet it depends on my
schedule I've got a bunch of stuff going
on tomorrow might a family in town
I would like to stream South Carolina
results tomorrow does anyone know if
it's the normal schedule where we would
get results around 8:00 or 9:00 p.m.
that's what I'm assuming and in kind of
thinking of my plans a user who has just
kind of like a face made with
punctuation says wood shifty beat Trump
in a knife duel absolutely Adam Schiff I
think is 49 years old
Trump Shinobi 73 year old the Trump
stands no chance whatsoever
mark chato sends a super chat will
Schroeder says what about Bernie Sanders
twitch we got it we found the Bernie
rally and we are standing by for Bernie
Sanders in Springfield Massachusetts
ranch elder says nobody new health care
could be so complicated I know right it
was completely unpredictable who could
have imagined noid says oops wwlp.com
Bernie interview then rally we're good
we've got a stream also ran says would
you agree there are similarities between
Trump's voice inflections during public
speaking and those of evangelical
preachers not really not really I don't
notice that let me take a look a listen
you see I think which is we call it MS
DNC right MS DNC but NBC I think is
worse than CNN I actually
and comcast a company that spends
millions looks like we've got an intro
going why I've ever seen consistently
fighting for the issues I've been
waiting my whole life for a candidate to
talk about my guess is I know a bunch of
people in the crowd I need everyone
where I grew up to work as hard as we
possibly can from now until Tuesday so
that we can win in Massachusetts and
then we need everyone in this room to
keep doing everything possible
throughout the rest of the campaign
season so we can win around the country
and win the Democratic nomination
and then win all the way to victory in
November but are you with me all right
we'll keep an eye on this and see when
Bernie comes out should be any second Oh
actually is it now is Bernie coming out
[Applause]
the former president of the
Massachusetts Teachers Association Oh an
organizer of Labor notes
Barbara manda Loney oh wait a second
Barbara Maddaloni
this was one of my high school teachers
wives I think see yeah there's that
third Wow wild stuff going on okay let
me keep answering questions till bernie
comes out Joseph said to Gotti says how
many days at the gym are leg days you
know of really just I think I do like
one day a week some people might have
seen my tweet today that I was at the
gym yeah I think I do one one day a week
of legs that's that's pretty good for me
being Argentinean you know legs aren't a
problem for me try to interpret that one
let me say thank you to Phillip Collier
who is new member number five of the
evening at join pakman.com help us get
to 25 new members it's a it's such a
modest goal we should be able to do it
quickly at join pakman.com and I'll say
great things about you as well if John
McKinney says if Trump loses re-election
do you think during his meltdown do you
think he'll have a heart attack I would
never wish that on him or anyone but
it's a realistic possibility he may be
rich but he is human I have no idea but
I but Trump is not in good health
James Montalbano says be careful don't
let Bernie's lawyers get your channel
taken down on a DMCA claim keep up the
work David that would be the tops
wouldn't it Jen's creative exploration
says thank you with a $10 super chat
mark chato says looking forward to
voting in a new and improved pres ok
Matthew Gautier has signed up on YouTube
stun ever says fork yes Burnie for
president we are hearing from someone I
know personally Barbara Barbara
Maddaloni related to mr. Maddaloni of
Western Massachusetts Fame let's let's
listen to a little bit of what she has
to say
Angela's educators have been rising up
and fighting for public education and
the public good educators are teaching
us about what it means when we use our
collective power they've been leading
the movements and bringing parents and
students in the community together to
fight for the public good
of course here all right so I think
mostly we want to see what what Bernie
has to say so we will keep an eye on
that let me say thanks to Joseph Murphy
Joseph Murphy is new member number six
tonight Thank You Joseph I so appreciate
your support
Joseph brutally taking advantage of the
coupon code 2020 now which is up there
which is a 66% discount absolutely
brutal no I'm kidding I we we love
giving discounts clockwork pineapple
says do you follow British politics or
are you put off by the whole Falklands
thing no because I'm Argentinian no I'm
not put off by the Falklands thing and I
follow British politics to a degree
followed brexit followed the Teresa May
situation Boris Johnson a bit we follow
it to some degree
Miguel Palacios Thanks so does that mean
the swing states are the only ones that
matter in general since the rest are
either blue or red basically yeah I mean
because we don't have a national popular
vote we have an electoral college really
what the election comes down to is the
contested states that are the ones that
can swing an election if you go to 538
you can actually see which states are
disproportionately likely to decide who
wins and therefore have
disproportionately large amounts of
power in the process let me say thank
you to alpha buds for subscribing with
twitch prime we are at all people are
asking where we are on twitch
subscriptions we are at 1146 I would
love to get to 1200 we're just 54 away
over on twitch which means if 10% of the
people watching on twitch were to sign
up we would we would get to 1200 let's
see let's just briefly see what's
happening at the Trump rally see what
he's ranting about
laying up Dara forever Tara
[Applause]
I just feel so bad for these pigs right
here but as we keep on winning
Washington Democrats keep on losing
their minds they've gone crazy
I mean nervous Nancy crying Chuck
Schumer crying Chuck a bunch of losers
the good citizens of South Carolina have
had a front row seat to the extremism of
the Democrat candidates whether it's his
character that nobody ever heard of him
I never heard I thought I knew all the
wealthy people this guy Tom Steyer mr.
impeachment how did that work out Tom
what I want him to say meaning he spent
millions and millions of dollars in Iowa
right millions he got less than 1% he
got like 1/3 of 1% I I wrote a little
note did you see it it said Tom it's not
so easy doing what I did is it not so
easy
please match as many all you have to do
is ask many my care than that for
fortunately I you he wish he never
started he wished he'd never many Mike
he wished she never started
he said well Chuck can do it anybody
noticed this kid seems to have quite a
twitch going it's kind of an unusual
thing may be triggered by the idiocy of
what Donald Trump is saying still
standing by for Bernie Sanders just down
the road from us in Springfield
Massachusetts
let's see people on twitch complaining
about slow mode okay we can so we can
speed that up because there's fewer
people in the chat right now we'll we'll
switch to five second instead of thirty
second mode as we wait for Bernie
Sanders here let me say a massive thank
you to oh I like this name sable Agustin
sable Agustin is new member number seven
of the evening Jacob Hemmer ik is new
member number eight of the evening and
knowledge gizmo Anderson is new member
number nine of the evening at join
pakman.com thank you so much for your
support I really do appreciate those
memberships over on YouTube let's look
at some super chats Kasper from Denmark
says hi David with the different polls
showing different results I was
wondering if there are right wing and
left wing polling companies and are
there companies that you consider
especially trustworthy I don't have any
special knowledge on this you can look
at 538 ranking of pollsters which
outlines all of that barbara caldwell
has grabbed the youtube membership
thanks Barbara miss Nene sends a super
chat Robert Grady has grabbed a YouTube
membership Bob Simon says I love you
David and the David Pakman Coffee you
know Bob I appreciate that
we um we we ended the David Pakman show
coffee a few months ago because we
decided it just it's not selling enough
for the amount of work that it is to
maintain the program so we sadly shut
the whole thing down but it was great
while it lasted I still drink coffee I
just no longer him in the business of
selling coffee
Shaner is 1981 says the dawn doesn't
seem to be able to control the volume of
his voice yeah I mean truck Trump's
delivery and and speech patterns are
bizarre to say the least let me say
thank you to spare foot for the
six-month twitch Prime subscription and
goober nuggets for the twitch prime
subscription that puts us 52 twitch
subscriptions away from our goal of 1200
very very exciting I see that we have
moderators on Twitch admonishing people
in the audience steering them away from
personal attacks you love to see it you
love to see it we want to encourage all
sorts of different conversation and
debate but we don't want personal
attacks that is for damn sure
mark Tenenbaum says thoughts on Bernie's
eat the rich rhetoric billionaires
shouldn't exist and policies wealth tax
8% after 10 billion effectively a
maximum wealth it'll never pass if it
helps him get votes good for him it will
never pass that's essentially my thought
on it at this point in time and in fact
a whole but it's not unique to Democrats
or Republicans that things that they say
they are going to do during their
campaigns aren't going to pass and that
doesn't mean we ignore it because it
still tells us what they want to do but
a lot of this stuff will never pass and
that applies to a whole bunch of
different policies many of which I know
you all know I already believe let me
say thank you to Sean Scott Sean Scott
is new member number 10 of the evening
10 of 25 really appreciate your support
let's see what's going on now getting
the crowd fired up here
[Music]
and who finally fixes our broken health
care system
by implementing Medicare Oh
in western Massachusetts people are
feeling the weight of ever rising
healthcare costs
and the brokenness of our system in my
district one man told me how he has mass
health coverage and that was the only
way he stayed out of debt when his heart
stopped and he needed a pacemaker but
when he was offered a promotion at work
he couldn't take it for fear of losing
that coverage
another woman who is caring for her
adult son who had a stroke said that he
needed ten sessions of physical therapy
a week to get better
yeah these stories that are
unfortunately all too common and we hear
them all the time they hate me they're
gonna put this all over the place we
have a pall of like 30,000 people inside
and out they're doing it outside too
we have a pole are you ready who do I so
in other words who's the weaker of the
two I'm not interested in who does
better no no I'm not interested
wait so ready in other words who do I
want to run against meaning meaning very
simple we put it into nice simple
language who the hell is easier to be
right so who is easier for us not me for
us to be ready
crazy Bernie
or sleepy Joe I should actually I'm
gonna put together a tweet if you guys
don't mind just pointing out the insane
okay watching both Trump and Bernie
rallies right now the stark difference
between the two in every way is stunning
not just level of English proficiency a
misspelled by the way but messaging and
adherence to reality it is quite
stunning it is it is really quite
stunning the difference between between
these two rallies even her even though I
have none I have done zero I have none I
have none I said I have four Indian
blood in me that she has no God can you
imagine let me say thank you to Louis
Brown who is new member number 11 today
thanks Louis I appreciate that I also
want to say thank you to Emma Giffen who
is new member number 12 today thank you
so much we are a roughly halfway to our
goal of 25 new members you can sign up
at join pakman.com it's quick it's easy
it's cheap it's delightful I will say
your name and then it becomes a real
party one thing you will say about me
I'm not a choker with all these people
for years
[Applause]
can have chokers we can't have chokers
as your president so Elizabeth Warren's
plan to eliminate America's borders and
that's what you would or Minnie Mike's
plan to eliminate your Second Amendment
and take away your guns up
this many Mike wants to take away you go
the insanity of the Democrat Party is
why millions of registered Democrat
voters are joining our movement they are
I don't know about millions that that
I'm unsure about Michael Kramer says
what is the what is seizing the means of
production mean in a post-industrial
economy is the government going to
nationalize app developers and retail
stores
again it's not gonna happen it's not
gonna happen Thoreau for Beck says is
the common mail section of your web page
being monitored ie a functioning b2b
communication channel b2b business to
business listen I'm gonna I'm gonna tell
you guys something that we don't we
don't usually talk about here at the
David Pakman show okay okay so if
actually if Bernie comes out then you're
not going to hear this but let's just
see who's coming out next because I'm
gonna explain something to folks in the
audience here which you might find
interesting okay well we've got music
going on is Bernie coming out now
because if so we're gonna we're gonna
listen to Bernie a little bit so listen
here's the thing we have a contact form
on our website
Oh bernie is coming out okay I'll tell
remind me to tell this story later
because we have a whole system actually
and why is the level low all of a sudden
I've got it absolutely maxed out
okay that music is gonna get us in
trouble probably let's hopefully they're
turning it down now a few people here
tonight thank you all very much for
coming out
let me begin by thanking Baylor Fleck
for that great music let me thank Fe her
again let me thank Representative Paul
mark let me thank Barbara Maddaloni mark
and I want to thank Senator Jamie
Eldridge and representative Lindsay
Zapdos because they are fighting for
exactly what all of us are fighting for
healthcare as a human right human we are
here together for two fundamental
purposes number one we are united as a
people we are united together to make
sure that we defeat Donald Trump the
worst president in the modern history of
this country right
Donald Trump is a pathological liar I
love that and no matter what your
political view may be you know that we
cannot continue having someone whose
word means nothing because he lies all
the time
that's true Donald Trump is running one
of the most corrupt administration's in
the history of this country it's Tara
quite frankly Donald Trump apparently
never read the Constitution of the
United States and every day with his
attacks on the media with his attacks on
the judiciary with his attacks on
Congress he is undermining American
democracy and moving this country toward
an autocracy now just over contrast
let's now look at the Trump rally you
know that right he's the chairman of the
Senate Judiciary Committee Sol Gordon so
important senator Graham has been
leading the charge to help us confirm a
record number of judges to uphold the
Constitution so over here you have Trump
bragging about the horrible people that
he has been appointing potentially for
life and then here we have an actual
positive mess on and he said Donald
Trump I'm a friend of working people
[Music]
now that is the biggest crock that I
have ever heard Trump promised the
American people that he would provide
health care to everybody and yet his
president he tried to throw thirty-two
million people off of the health care
they have tried to do away with the
protections that people with
pre-existing conditions have
when Trump was running for office he
said well my tax plan is going to
benefit working families not the rich he
[Music]
83% of the benefits of that plan that he
pushed through over a 10-year period
goes to the top 1%
Donald Trump said you know I am a
different type of Republican I'm not
gonna cut Medicare Medicaid or social
security he lied
take a look at his budgets year after
year calling for massive cuts to
Medicare Medicaid and Social Security
we are going to defeat Donald Trump
because the American people are sick and
tired of a government that works for the
rich and it goes everybody else that
message of economic populism
fundamentally is really what this is
about right it's sort of Trump's faux
populism which even if it was real would
be right populism which is not that far
actually if people really want to dig
into this stuff check out federico
Finkelstein's work he's a fellow
Argentinean but a fellow Argentinean Jew
like me I might add who cares so I'm
just kidding around but he teaches at
the new school in New York City and he
has talked about how populism in some
sense has its roots in totalitarian
fascism in its application of course
it's a very different thing trump's
version of right populism has a lot in
common with fascism and authoritarianism
as many of you probably noticed let me
thank a couple people and then we'll get
back to the speeches I want to say
thanks to Carolina for gifting a
tier-one sub on twitch invalid axiom has
subscribed for three months I so
appreciate that let me say thank you if
you're just joining us we do have a goal
of 25 new members tonight let me say
thanks to Richard Gaston who is new
member number thirteen tonight and
Hunter Rupp Nick who is new member
number fourteen tonight over on YouTube
via super chat I want to say thanks to
Phil Kelly and Gabriel Fernandez says do
you think that Cuba comments ruined
Bernie's chances in Florida my Cuban
family is now against him can Democrats
win without Florida well the the
question about the primary in Florida is
a different one than the general I'm not
even thinking about the general yet we
have to see who comes away victorious in
in Florida in the primary Florida of
course not voting on Super Tuesday I
think they vote later in March if if I
recall correctly let me also say thank
you to diz Ethan slam Barry for the
twitch prime sub and Dan of Earth for
the twitch prime sub let's listen to a
little bit of Trump oh no it's Tim we
don't want to hear Tim Scott or Lindsey
Graham speak we'll stick with Laverne
rally for now it is a movement that says
to the corporate elite you cannot have
it all we're coming back and what this
campaign is doing is bringing together
blacks and whites and Latinos Native
Americans Asian Americans the gay
community the straight community we are
standing together for an agenda that
works for all of us not just wealthy
campaign contributors and I'll tell you
one of the things that I'm very very
proud of and I want all of you to be
proud of our campaign does not have a
super PAC
[Applause]
okay let's talk about this a little bit
because this has been got become an
important thing and and so here's the
deal it's true that Bernie doesn't have
a super PAC and that's great
it's gotten a little slippery when
people talk about well what about super
PACs that support Bernie and Bernie's
right that he can't control what other
super PACs do I think that this entire
issue needs to be reframed and the way I
would reframe it is listen I can't
control without what other people do I
can't control why other people support
me and right now it's legal to have a
super PAC and support whoever the hell
you want what I can tell you is this I
don't have a super PAC any means to get
me into office instead of Trump is good
and once I'm there I will try to fix the
system of broken campaign finance you
know I think that it's otherwise it's
going to get a little slippery otherwise
because having a super having a super
PAC versus benefiting from super PACs
that support you it starts to become
gray if I were Bernie and I'm not I
would try to have some language about
you know any might be supported who
knows who supports me I don't have a
super PAC and I would work to end super
PACs if I were President of the United
States or something along those lines
and I would be fine with that I wouldn't
be dissuaded from voting for Bernie if
he said listen if I'm the nominee
there's gonna be money pouring in from
all sorts of proof super PACs they won't
be mine I don't care defeating Trump is
the most important thing and once I
defeat Trump I'll fix this campaign
finance system that's broken that would
resonate with me and I would I would be
totally comfortable with that I don't
care
[Applause]
[Music]
that's for sure the insurance industry
is getting nervous the drug companies
who draw to us the highest prices in the
world for prescription drugs they're
getting nervous I haven't heard this
pump so fuel industry that's destroying
this planet getting nervous the prison
industrial complex that getting nervous
I see people who are saying that I'm
making a [ __ ] argument about super
PACs I'm not making an argument all I'm
saying is Bernie if he's the nominee
will be the beneficiary of a whole bunch
of super PAC money and people are gonna
try to call him out on it and I would
like to see him circumvent that in
advance I'm not making any argument I'm
not it's like I'm just a messenger here
and I'm giving an opinion as to what the
message should be I'm not making an
argument one way or the other and what
they say is they say Oh Bernie can't be
Trump
[Applause]
well I would urge them to take a look at
the last 60 national polls
[Applause]
and they will find that 56 out of 60
times we be trouble I would urge them to
take a look at battleground states like
Michigan Pennsylvania Wisconsin weeping
Trump see they're not worried that I
can't be Trump they're worried that we
will be trouble
and the reason we're gonna be Trump is
because of you right now as we speak all
over this country as we approach Super
Tuesday
there are thousands and thousands of
people knocking on doors making the
telephone calls that we have to make
that is why we won the popular vote in
Iowa why we won New Hampshire why we won
Nevada and of course tomorrow February
29th the South Carolina primary and we
will have those results for you let me
say thanks to a few other twitch
subscribers Thailand says hair looking
good as always fellow David Thank You Q
79 has subscribed with prime donkey show
has subscribed at tier-one Zippo
lincoln-mercury has subscribed with
prime let me read a couple of Super
chats here
hound dog says do you think Bernie could
win states like West Virginia or
Kentucky in the general if he campaigned
hard enough there on economic populism
in health care I don't think so but
here's what you have to understand even
if he could if Bernie could win Western
West Virginia with enough work that
amount of work would if put into
Wisconsin and North Carolina and Ohio or
Pennsylvania more easily win him though
so there's no world in which like if
Bernie's going to win West Virginia with
enough effort that means more moderate
states he would definitely win which
means West Virginia wouldn't matter in
the final math of it so that that's what
you have to consider Ryan may Nikki says
thank you for being a voice of reason
and calm consideration during these
turbulent times please keep up the good
work and enjoy the fiber Thank You Ryan
a DD says can you get that Portuguese
dog on the David Pakman show love that
dog oh yeah on my Instagram page there's
video of a Portuguese dog not a not a
Portuguese water dog just a dog in
Portugal that loves my show and also I
posted my new professional headshot
today maybe like maybe it maybe I'm
kidding and people are going absolutely
bonkers saying that it would be that my
career would be over if I started using
the picture I posted today to my
Instagram account as as my professional
head
shot let's listen just a little bit to
trump and remember we're looking at the
contrast here between the Trump rally
and the Bernie rally black poverty
levels are the lowest ever recorded in
the history of our country for decades
Democrat politicians betrayed
african-americans they forced their
children into failing schools they ship
their jobs to foreign countries they
push their unfair sentencing policies
you know about that Alice you know Alice
and they favored illegal aliens over
their own constituents you know that
okay and then in contrast the Bernie
rally culture of America
you know people fought and died no
prompter people fought and died for our
right to vote and we have got to stand
up and fight for democracy get involved
in the political process
[Applause]
so you know politically correct not
using a plastic bottle
[Applause]
and what does that mean you know some of
you may have seen the foot fight that
appeared to be a debate the other night
and it's sad because we need serious
discussion there are a lot of serious
crises facing this country and they have
to be discussed and that was not a
mechanism to do that but what politics
is about really when you get beyond what
media tries to do it's not complicated
it is saying what is going on in our
country today how did we get to where we
are and where do we want to go and when
we talk about where we want to go I
always remember a brilliant short
statement by Nelson Mandela and what
Mandela said I want you to think about
what he said he said everything is
impossible until it happens
[Music]
everything is impossible until it
happens it was impossible a hundred plus
years ago for workers before me Union
couldn't happen it was impossible for
the african-american community to stand
up and get the right to vote and to
defeat racism impossible for women to
get the right to vote so in contrast to
this message again just for comparison
the Trump rally
those empty hopes all over the all over
the country all over this state all
around the world we are demanding trade
that is fair and my all-time favorite
word reciprocal reciprocal got it before
he learned that word last week after
years of building up other countries we
are finally rebuilding our country by we
are finally putting America first
America first so again allusions to a
nationalist and even anti-semitic
overtones while Bernie working with no
teleprompter actually talking about
lifting people up should of reality
don't listen to Congress and their
definition of reality ask yourself where
this great country should be going
[Applause]
and then when you do that and when you
look at the issues facing the country
and you know them better than I and then
you say where we want to go the answers
are not hard number one never ever
forget that today you were living in the
wealthiest country in the history of the
world that's what y'all but nobody knows
it because almost all of the income and
wealth goes to the top 1%
[Applause]
so when we look at the issues we say
okay in America today we have tens and
tens of millions of people who are
working for starvation wages that's a
fact
we're gonna raise the federal minimum
wage to fifteen bucks an hour we're
going to end the absurdity of women
making 80 cents on the dollar compared
to men
I wish someone would get Bernie the
right math on that because that 80 cent
number is not it's not the right number
and I don't know I forgive me and that I
care about the exact facts I feel like
somebody should get him the right number
on that but there would probably be
political repercussions because a lot of
people still believe the 80 cent number
[Applause]
we proposal in that in a four year
period will double the number of workers
in the trade union movement
[Music]
this is the wealthiest country on earth
our infrastructure roads bridges people
asking for the right number it's about
91 cents on the dollar we've got a deep
dive on this on our channel and that's
still not okay but I I think we just
need to work with with what is actually
the right number a good paying union
jobs
[Applause]
[Music]
in America 500,000 people should not be
homeless tonight and 18 million families
should not be spending fifty percent of
their income on housing we're gonna
build 10 million units of low-income and
affordable housing and when we talk
about an agenda that works for working
people we understand that there is
nothing more important than education
we understand that zero through four are
the most important years of human
development and we cannot understand why
we continue to have a dysfunctional
childcare system and that is why
together we will have universal high
quality affordable childcare every
family in America
all right let's briefly check in on the
Trump rally momentarily let me first
make sure I'm thanking everybody donkey
show thank you again for gifting another
sub donkey show has now gifted 80 subs
on our channel only 90 behind the number
one gift er turkey bacon and cheese also
want to say thanks to MC 98 TW 2018 for
the twitch prime sub and missus bass
dude appreciate you as well let me say a
huge thank you to Donna Reed who is new
member number 15 this evening at join
pakman.com as well as Krystal Patterson
whose new member number 16 tonight let's
take a brief check-in we are sort of
switching back and forth between the two
rallies here's Donald Trump's rally
juh last year how many people did you
kill last year with a knife because they
like knives because they're go pain
'full this is the kind of people that we
were letting into our country ice has
taken them out of our country by the
thousands by the thousand
last year ice officers arrested 12,000
criminal aliens charged
so here Trump's bragging about Hispanic
people getting arrested let's see what
Bernie's talking about the best and the
brightest into education I hope many of
you will give thought to becoming
teachers and my view is that no teacher
in America should earn less than $60,000
a year and if you believe in education
you understand that free public
education is not just K through 12 we've
got to make public colleges and
universities tuition-free
[Applause]
and if you think outside of the box and
if you think about a government that
represents workers and not billionaires
then you ask yourself how did it happen
to 12 years ago against my vote Congress
voted to bail out the crooks on Wall
Street
[Music]
how did it happen that two years ago
Trump gave his billionaire friends and
large corporations a trillion dollar tax
cut well if we can bail out the crooks
on Wall Street you know what we can do
we can cancel all student debt in
America
[Applause]
[Music]
and let me pick up on a point that Jamie
Eldridge and Lindsay sabbith also talked
about and that is we will end the
international disgrace of being the only
major country on earth not to guarantee
health care every man woman and child as
a human right and I want all of you to
understand us right now in America we
are spending twice as much as the people
in Canada and in virtually every other
major country we are spending $11,000
every man woman and child for health
care that is an outrageous sum of money
but for all of that money we end up with
87 million people uninsured or
underinsured and let me tell you about
underinsured means that you got high
deductibles high co-payment and you
hesitate to go to a doctor when you
should that's gonna get ugly real quick
when people should be seen and treated
for coronavirus but they are
underinsured the way that Bernie Sanders
is talking about is it gonna get ugly
very very quick let me say thank you to
a couple of other people who have
grabbed memberships on my website I want
to say thanks to David Cal Muir who is
new member number 17 and oh I guess
that's it
super chat questions continuing to come
in on youtube nexus says it sends a
super chat if Trump drops pence for
Nikki hailey do you think that would be
a game-changer in my opinion it would be
the excuse a lot need to vote for Trump
enough to matter I am NOT even thinking
about that because I find it so
inconceivable that Donald Trump is going
to change his running mate if you have
reason to suspect otherwise by all means
let me know let's see what's happening
at Trump's magda rally which I believe
should almost count as child abuse if
you bring under
kids to it in four years from now for
your trial and about two percent come
back and they're the ones that are the
dumbest people I've ever seen two
percent nobody comes back it's crazy but
we're getting it changed and it would be
so easy they called loopholes loopholes
that word alone they call loopholes it
would be so easy if we had some democrat
support we don't have any democrat
support they want open borders they
don't care about crime Border Patrol has
seized the largest amount of deadly
narcotics ever in the history of our
country this last year we have deported
record numbers of gang members we are
building the wall faster than ever and
we will soon be building more than one
mile a day that is very much on for
Washington Democrats have never been
more extreme 132 congressional Democrats
have signed up for Bernie Sanders health
care takeover they want to take away
yelp signed up even that terminology is
a joke Ballmer talked about it a hundred
years of pork is enough now is the time
for action
[Applause]
last year last year while 87 million
people were uninsured or underinsured
and we paid the highest prices in the
world for drugs the healthcare industry
made a hundred billion dollars in profit
so today we say to the healthcare
industry the function of a rational and
humane healthcare system is to provide
quality care for all not to make
billions in profits for the healthcare
industry now we got a president who
embarrasses us every day but he is also
embarrassing and endangering the entire
world Donald Trump continues to believe
that climate change is a hoax
well I myself think that Donald Trump is
a hoax that's not a bad line with the
wholesome line
[Applause]
now I'm gonna make a radical suggestion
to you are you all ready for a radical
suggestion don't vote now we got
emergency medical service available if
anybody collapses but here it comes our
administration will believe in science
[Applause]
and what the scientists are telling us
is that the situation regarding climate
change is even worse than they had
previously thought what they are saying
is they have underestimated the speed
and severity in which climate change is
ravaging our country and the planet what
they are telling us is that the polar
ice caps are melting and a faster rate
than they had previously thought that
the oceans are warming and a faster rate
that they are thought and the sea levels
are going up and up at a faster rate
what they are telling us is that there
is more drought than they anticipated
more extreme weather disturbances what
they are telling us is that the ocean is
becoming more acidic which means fish
are dying and people who get their
protein from the ocean will no longer be
able to do that and what the United
Nations is telling us is if we don't get
our act together there will be several
hundred million climate refugees by the
end of the century that is what the
scientists not Bernie Sanders that's
what the scientists are telling us and
that is why that is why unapologetically
I have introduced the most sweeping
climate change proposal ever introduced
by any candidate for federal law
[Music]
based on the principles of the green New
Deal this proposal will create up to 20
million good-paying union jobs as we
transform our energy system away from
fossil fuel to energy efficiency and
sustainable energy and because climate
change is obviously not just an American
issue but a global issue my job if I'm
elected president is to tell China tell
Russia tell India tell Pakistan that we
are in this together and that maybe just
maybe instead of spending 1.8 trillion
dollars a year on weapons of destruction
maybe we should pool our resources fight
our common enemy which is climate change
[Applause]
and when we talk about issues that must
be addressed we have got to deal with a
broken and racist criminal justice
system it is not acceptable to me nor to
you that we have more people in jail
today disproportionately
african-american Latino and Native
American than any other country on earth
and that is why together we are going to
invest in our young people making sure
they have good jobs all right let's uh
we're getting now to the sort of a stock
part of Bernie's stump speech so let me
answer some questions
hound dog says ever notice that the
stars on the Republican logo or
pentagrams no I have not noticed that
Jenna kill pop says keep up the quality
hardwork David thanks Jenna
thanks to Catherine Brown for signing up
me gay Palacios says medicare-for-all
would get people to be unweighting list
to see a doctor since everyone is going
to want to visit the best doctor in town
what are your thoughts if you go from
having no care to having care and your
choices are to visit of a perfectly fine
board-certified doctor or quote the best
doctor and having to wait I think most
people are just going to go to a doctor
that that's my sense of it
Ryan manake says me again it's
pronounced Meineke okay Ryan my Nikki I
noticed you mentioned the impact the
coronavirus will have on the healthcare
system when it begins to spread here
would you make a video about the risk it
poses to the United States we already
have a number of videos about that and
it does it is a major major issue let me
say thank you to Matthias von Romme Berg
who is new member number 18 of the
evening at join pakman.com thanks
Matthias let me also say thank you to HJ
Mun works for the twitch Prime
subscription and Moe Ron moe ron has
subscribed with twitch and says nothing
other than radical radical let's listen
to a bit of what's going on with Trump
Republican Party you know they came to
me a group of people and they wanted
criminal justice reform and I wasn't
sure about the issue but we had a lot of
great Republicans very much in favor of
it
including people that happened to be
right
today and they were very much he's
referring flashy guy stuff for you and
criminal justice reform you saw Alice
Johnson come out of prison 22 years she
had another 20 years left think of it
for a phone call a great woman but we
have many people coming out that
shouldn't be there for anywhere near
those terms not for those terms but they
came to see me a group a group of people
came Van Jones he came up oh thank you
sir they needed four senators they
needed help
I called Lindsey I called everybody I
called Tim who was so great on
everything I called everybody they
needed four senators and maybe five and
they needed help with some of the ones
that weren't moving in the right
direction and I gave it to him and I got
it and it was not easy and we got
criminal justice reform what a hero
and then this Van Jones has a program
that gets no ratings absolutely at all
and they say Van Jones wants to thank
everybody for criminal justice reform so
I called our great first lady over and
said darling please take a look it's
gonna be so nice because honestly look
they couldn't have done even close
without being I got all these people
together man it's just it's just the
lyrium it's complete and total delirium
over there
[Applause]
[Music]
now as a member of the United States
Senate I hear a lot of speeches on the
Senate floor and I hear them from
conservative Republicans who tell us
that they believe in small government
and they believe in getting the
government off the backs of the American
people well I say to those hypocrites if
you believe in getting the government
off the backs of the American people
understand that it is women who have a
right to control their own bodies not
the government
say here is a promise you can take to
the bank
I will never nominate anyone to the
Supreme Court or the federal bench who
is not 100 percent Pro Rho V wait there
yeah we will fight to codify put into
law Rho V wait let me time but I and his
friends want to severely cut funding for
Planned Parenthood well we've got some
bad news for them because we're gonna
expand funding for planting some good
questions coming in that I want to keep
answering here extreme tuber 7 says so
we have downer Trump and upper Trump
what do you call the middle of that yeah
I don't know tonight it's kind of a
weird in between AC 0 510 is asking is
Trump really sweaty he does seem quite
sweaty it's hard to tell exactly what's
going on and you know I've seen from
sweaty ER his upper lip does seem a
little bit glossy there but but I don't
know
let's see wormwood says David stop
shilling for big hair I can't help it I
can't help it do you want to see big
hair check out my the picture I posted
to Instagram today Eric o says I felt
compelled to make a video explaining why
ACA volume 2 plus public options slash
Medicare for all who want it are
terrifying and we need em for a from an
MD perspective a real doctor reacts to
the current democratic healthcare debate
ok that is a mouthful but thank you I
appreciate that let me say thanks to
Jennifer Coates who is new member number
19 of the evening if we do get to 25 new
members I will wide open the phone lines
when these rallies are over well we are
only six new members away at join
pakman.com from that level
then every family in America has its
share of problems and when my family
cares about your family and your family
cares about my family we all do better
Edda and the other thing that us not me
reflects is an understanding of the
power structure in America something
that has not talked about terribly much
in the media and what it means is that
no president and I'm the only candidate
I think would tell you this no president
Bernie Sanders or anybody else can do it
alone
because what we are doing is taking on
extraordinary power I know these guys
I'm a senator I know Wall Street and I
know the insurance companies and I know
the drug companies and I know the fossil
fuel industry and I know the
military-industrial complex I know the
prison industrial complex I know their
incredible power and their enormous
amounts of money that they have they are
very very powerful if we are going to
transform this country the only way we
do it is together
[Applause]
[Music]
when millions of working people stand up
and demand decent wages we're gonna get
decent wages when people stand up and
say we're not going to pay fifty percent
of our income in housing we're gonna
build the affordable housing we need
when moms and dads demand affordable
high-quality childcare
we'll get affordable high quality
childcare when young people say they
don't want to leave college deeply in
debt
we'll get free tuition at public
colleges again going through the talking
points and policy positions that he is
known for and talking about his vision
while Donald Trump brags about ice
arresting his Hispanic people in South
Carolina Bernie right by my hometown of
my adoptive hometown so to speak in
Springfield Massachusetts just up the
road from Northampton Massachusetts
super chats coming in guy LeFleur says I
don't know if you saw on Tuesday but you
are cool and good thank you guy I
appreciate that
Joe Raider says David are you buying the
dip I'm not going out of my way to buy
shares of stock now that they are down
drastically over the last week but I
tend to do buys twice a month regardless
of what's going on if stocks are up or
if stocks are down and so or in the
first few days of March I will do my
normal buy and in the third week of
March I will do my normal buy and I'll
kind of keep dollar cost averaging in
and that is not financial advice of
course to anybody in particular every
situation is different and nothing I say
could possibly apply to everybody's
financial situation let me say thank you
and welcome to windows ambi who has
subscribed with twitch prime snowfall
and evergreens has subscribed with prime
and sparks and shorts has subscribed
with prime we are now 37 twitch
subscribers away from our goal as Bernie
wraps
[Music]
okay and we don't want to get any kind
of copyright issues because of the music
Bernie Sanders with a relatively short
rally compared to Donald Trump but of
course saying much more as Donald Trump
as you will you see here continues to
drone on and on ending the AIDS epidemic
nobody thought this was possible unless
now than nine years that it should have
been started before and you know it will
end the AIDS epidemic who would have
thought we could have done that we will
land the first woman on the moon and
become the first nation in the world to
plant our flag on Mars you have to land
on moon and then you go tomorrow
we will defend privacy free speech
religious liberty and the right to keep
and bear arms
[Applause]
and above all we will never stop
fighting for the sacred values that bind
us together as one America we support
protect and defend the Constitution of
the United States is from going to end
aids or cure AIDS I guess I'm unsure
about about about that particular piece
let me say thank you to new bid de la
serda who is new member number 20 of the
evening thank you so much very much
appreciate that support Bernie Sanders
has concluded his rally we have a goal
of 25 new members if we get there we
will open up the phone lines it sort of
seems like Trump is starting to wind
down I say let's just get those last
five members that join pakman.com and
open the phone lines I want to hear from
you guys momentarily and we live by the
words of our national motto In God We
Trust
from Greenville to Columbia and from
Myrtle Beach to Hilton Head - right here
in Charleston this state is home to some
of the toughest men and strongest women
ever to walk on the face of the earth
it's true getting into the sweatiest
phase we stand on the shoulders of
American patriots who have crossed the
oceans blazed the trails settle the
continent tame the wilderness dug out
the Panama Canal laid down the railroads
revolutionized industry liberated
millions from poverty hunger and disease
one two world wars defeated fascism and
communism and hate America the single
greatest nation in the history of the
world and we are making it greater every
single day
Wow
yeah there you go
Janek he'll pop says the only left thing
he said got zero applause Trump
what was the left thing he said the
prison reform stuff Thoreau fir Beck
says the suspense is unbearable what
about the cliffhanger the story about
contacting through the webpage and the
whole system you put in place I will
tell the story I will tell the story
when when when Trump wraps up let me say
welcome to be Col D I think I know who
that is who has subscribed for one month
at Tier one let me say thanks to Mike
Tron 3030
who has also subscribed for one month at
Tier one over on Twitch very much
appreciate that thank you also want to
oh I guess that's it yeah I don't have
anybody else to thank that's that's ed
Trump it looks like he's starting to
lose steam and sweat excessively so my
guess is we don't have more than five or
ten minutes left and some actually
called they're two great senators into a
big meeting at Town Hall and they said
Senator Scott Senator Lindsey Graham
great tired of winning in South Carolina
can't do it anymore
it's too much it's too much we've had
years where we weren't winning and it
was okay we couldn't get jobs we took it
easy but we we just want you to go and
see your friend the president and we
want you to represent us that we want
you to say mr. president South Carolina
is tired of winning we don't want to win
anymore
we are tired sick tired of winning we're
getting to the delusional part if you
were wondering if you thought it was all
delusional up until now this is really
it Janek he'll pop says the first woman
on the moon
oh yeah Trump said he was gonna put the
first woman on the moon and I guess
there wasn't that much applause I didn't
notice that much one way or the other
didn't didn't stand out I guess in any
way let me say thanks to Jimmy Avanza
who is new member number 21 tonight
Benjamin a bar or a bar is new member
number 22 folks we are just three
members from opening the phone lines and
just to entice people a little more at
25 members I will tell the story of
our contact form and whoever is new
member number 25 gets a free item on me
from the David Pakman show online store
at david pakman.com slash gear number 25
and the last three could happen quick so
I wouldn't try to time it too precisely
because together we will make America
wealthy again we will make America
strong again we will make America proud
again taking away will make America safe
again
and we will make America great again
Thank You South Carolina thank you oh
boy whoa we got to get that music off
before things get too crazy these
children's lives how will these
children's lives be irreparably damaged
by this seminal experience particularly
this guy right here what do you predict
is the future for these children and
what do you believe it's it's very very
ugly very very very ugly I I don't even
know what to what what to tell you about
all of this it is it is vile it is
completely and totally vile yeah
incredible TV says I can't believe I'm
coming up on one year of being a member
I felt trapped in the political
apparatus and couldn't find quality
progressive media that was until I found
the Pakman keep it player PAC thank you
thank you very much I really do
appreciate that that support let me say
thank you to mark s who is new member
number 23 this evening if we get to 25
new members and we are so close I will
tell the contact form story we will open
the phone lines and new member 25 we're
looking at this very strongly so
strongly that we're just gonna do it new
member not 25 tonight gets a free item
t-shirt coffee mug whatever you want
from the David Pakman show online store
now in the meantime let me say thank you
to go
ooh for the two-month subscription with
twitch prime over on twitch and it has
been an incredible night an incredible
night of policy ideas from Bernard
Sanders in Springfield Massachusetts and
insults and bragging about arresting
Hispanics from Donald Trump in South
Carolina in advance of tomorrow's
primary let me say thank you to reigning
champ for the twitch Prime subscription
I really do appreciate that so very much
thanks to drift juice for grabbing a
youtube subscription this has actually
ended I'm curious what else we have
going on that is uh that is live how can
we just search for live stuff let's see
if I go to trending no if I type live
and then oh no that's but that's over as
well interesting the Trump rally still
showing is live in some places maybe
we'll just kind of let it run on a loop
here as Donald Trump did very much very
very much embarrass himself earlier
today we are waiting on that new
membership number 25 24 and 25 new
member number 25 gets a free item on me
and we will also open up the phone lines
I predict it's going to happen so I'll
get that cued up Jody Godwin says little
short of money right now but good show
David thank you and also thanks to lil
miss bleah 1981 for the YouTube channel
subscription let's see okay I believe we
have new member number 25 let's see you
let's go in order folks before things
get crazy new member number 24 tonight
is Catherine ivy Thank You Catherine new
member number 25 getting a free item
from the David Pakman show store is mark
Jordan thanks mark I appreciate that
email me pick out an item give me your
mailing address and we will get that
over to you Edwin Vega is new member
number 26 tonight Chris Mackin is new
member number 27 and Cory garrulous is
new member number 20
eight alright so we're gonna open up the
phone lines momentarily as promised
you can call in at six one seven eight
three zero forty seven fifty let me tell
you the contact form story okay so
here's the deal
earlier today someone asked what does
your contact form work when people write
in on your contact form are you getting
that is that being reviewed let me give
you a little bit of a behind-the-scenes
here at the David Pakman show okay I
think if people want at any point if
people don't like this story you can
interrupt it okay but I think people are
going to like this story when the david
pakman show started we set up a website
and a contact form and I was desperate
desperate for people to write in I
wanted people to engage I wanted people
to watch and a little to all that stuff
and we didn't get any emails because we
didn't have any audience and slowly but
surely over time the david pakman show
audience grew to the point where we
needed we were getting a lot of spam
through our contact forum we needed to
set up CAPTCHA and the number of emails
that were coming in daily from our
contact form and to me because it's not
that hard to figure out my email address
started growing and growing and growing
to the tune of hundreds of viewer emails
per day coming in through the contact
form not nothing you know to say about
thousands of YouTube comments and all of
this different stuff so eventually we
had to put in place a system where there
are people who email the show every day
okay and I know some of them are
watching right now and I love that
people are so engaged that they're
emailing the show every day but it's too
much it's too much and we are so busy
producing the show dealing with you know
membership payment issues dealing with
affiliate issues booking live
appearances all of this different stuff
that I can't correspond with people
individually via email I'm busy doing
the show this is a reality okay and so
we have a system in place where if you
go to our website and you use the
contact form it is triaged by our team
and if it's just a political comment and
I know a lot of people are gonna be
furious about this and a lot of people
aren't gonna like me if you're going to
our contact form and send
something like hey cover this story or
cover that story it's being triaged the
ideas are compiled and we'll review them
every once in a while and if there's
good suggestions we pick them out if
you're emailing me directly because you
figured out my email and you email me
regularly almost guaranteed your email
is being Auto filtered and I'm never
seeing it that's the reality and then on
every once in a while all of those
messages that are Auto filtered into a
specific separate email address are
looked at and if there are threats they
get forwarded to the f.b.i if they are
payment related issues we respond and
help people out but I'm not able to
engage in political discussion via via
email we're too busy with the show I say
this with total peace and love and if
you are emailing me regularly
I'm not seeing it but I am if there's
anything that needs action I am getting
a report about it that's the reality
that's that's the story sorry - sorry to
break it to folks okay let's take some
phone calls at 6 1 7 8 3 0 437 thank you
for calling in to the David Pakman show
please do not use speakerphone have your
question ready and little app weren't
able to call out you are area code okay
there we go we're gonna get the phone
calls momentarily at 6 1 7 8 3 0 47 50
but there are other people that I need
to thank before we do that so let me
just make sure I'm all set on our phone
system there we go
okay let me say a couple of thank-yous
let me say thank you to Mike Hawk ok
Michael Hawk not an idiot and Daniel
Garcia is new member number 30 of the
evening thank you very much I appreciate
that I also want to say thank you on
twitch to a c05 1 z10 who has now gifted
five more subscriptions and AC zero five
one zero is now number four in our list
of all-time top gift errs and I really
do appreciate that thank you so much
over on YouTube
J ron h74 says my name is pronounced
jenna pronounced Jennifer Cody number 19
I've enjoyed your YouTube streams keep
up the good work from New Hampshire very
nice thank you David Melo says I love
how Trump brings up the laying of the
railroads as a great American feat when
the majority was with the labor of
immigrants he doesn't care he doesn't
know
and Daniel Krieger says worst story ever
I apologize all right let's pick up on
some folks calling in let's go first to
our caller from the 206 area code who's
calling today from 206 hey David my name
is Josh yes I can't Josh go ahead hey a
long time let's have the show really
doing questions for you regarding the
Medicare for all now I currently was an
Idaho where they recently adopted to
expand the Medicaid to cover that back
gap when you're not making enough for
making too little right but I'm sorry
I'm currently enrolled in Medicaid in
Idaho I mean I have talked to my doctor
recently and he has said that there has
been a lot of mechanisms put in place to
help her rather not help people get the
care that they need and I'm serious to
know and we can expect that kind of
treatment to go on if we do adopt a
medicare-for-all type system well a lot
of the gaps that exist are gaps because
there are gaps between systems if you
only have one system you eliminate a lot
of those gaps but without knowing more
about the specifics it'd be really hard
for me to say exactly what you're
referring to okay all right
well I can't really elaborate any more
at this time but I just wanted to all
right thank you very much I appreciate
the phone call let's go next to Jason
now Jason with peace and love Jason from
the seven one six I have a note that
last time you called in my voice was
echoing and badly and I had to hang up
on you I hope that doesn't happen today
oh and it is happening I'm hearing my
own voice on like a 10-second delay
hey Jason is there any way that we can
make it so I'm not hearing my own voice
coming back to me
no can I say something and to me on your
phone or are you listening to me on
YouTube right now I can hear his own
voice Jason I'm sorry I gotta let you go
I had it in the notes Jason we asked
with peace and love for you to not call
back in with the echo i think jason has
you he has his phone muted and he's
listening on the stream so his own voice
is feeding back in that is just very
very poor call or etiquette I'm sorry
Jason let's go next to our caller from
the seven-one-seven who's calling in
today from 7 1 700 I think that's me yes
it is David can you hear me yes I can
all right
so David I just want to say real quick
huge fan started listening to kolinsky
maybe a year ago you mentioned you you
and your show and I also listened to Joe
Rogan found your show through that
program as well you know so yeah very
cool so question for you is canvassing
door to door is there any evidence for
this actually making a change you know
and the way people think I know you did
a lot of segments on murders are you
can't reach people are too far gone
where TFG is some people call it is
there any evidence or studies out there
that actually support you know if you go
to people who don't vote or people you
know are unconvinced or undecided
can you change their mind well I listen
there's a lot of different types of
canvassing most canvassing is not to
argue
with people to make drastic changes in
their politics canvassing for the most
part is not to canvass for a Democratic
candidate by going to houses known to
vote Republican and try to convince them
to vote for a Democrat for the most part
what you're doing is you are either one
strategy is if you're working for a
Democratic candidate you target
Democratic voters and you want a number
one gauge who they're thinking of voting
for and then strategize around get out
the vote for people that are likely to
support your candidate that's one
strategy the other is to find people who
are considering a different candidate
than the one you're supporting but they
are not yet a hundred percent and those
you identify and check back in so
there's a lot of different strategies
but for the most part the strategy the
primary strategy is not to find
Republicans and convince them to vote
for a Democrat that that is not right
primarily it's being done yeah yeah I
totally hear that and it makes so much
sense I know a lot of people that are
thinking oh you know I know people older
than me that I work with you know
thinking oh maybe Bloomberg can be in
the middle and capture voters who are
other Republicans that are more centrist
blah blah blah you know I feel like I
mean I know I'll be going door-to-door
for Bernie and this is in Pennsylvania
by the way I'll be going door-to-door
for Bernie when the time comes but I
feel like I can't even convince my own
family members and I am friends there
were Democrats and believe in the same
values as Bernie it seems as though
they're just you know maybe against
Bernie I'm not really sure why but I'm
just wondering it's tough to convince
people to change their minds especially
when would you know people get defensive
and when you present them with what to
you seem like obvious facts that support
one candidate over another
people often dig in further this is a
broader behavioral economics thing it's
very hard to get people to really change
their minds and there's a lot written
about you know the best techniques in
order to do that okay okay do you have
any examples out there anything
food for thought that I could share with
my own because I'm involved in that you
town in my own towns Democratic
Committee well I I would I would
primarily using Craddock method of
questioning of open-minded inquiry about
what is it that has made you decide to
vote for the person you're supporting
and what would make you change your mind
and support Bernie if you heard it and
start there and then work backwards
because a lot of people I know
Bernie's policies and they might say
well if Bernie had policy a B and C I'd
vote for him and maybe Bernie has those
policies already so I think open-minded
questioning is the way to start okay yep
I think I heard you say that before I
kind of forgot that
yeah like say you know so you're
supporting Elizabeth Warren what is it
about a little bit that that you like so
much sure and go that's a great way to
start a conversation non-judgmentally
listen I'm gonna let you go but I
appreciate the phone call very much let
me read a couple super chats waiting to
fade says canvassing sounds like
missionary work as one who grew up
Mormon I tend to try to avoid Canvassers
in canvassing myself yeah me too I don't
I don't I'm not planning to do it myself
certainly but uh it is it is in some
cases people believe it is God's work
the Mormons do anyway and I don't maybe
some of more religious political
canvassers as well let's go next to Sam
from the 2:02 Sam from the 2:02 what's
up Sam hi David real quick I just well
first of all how are you doing I'm doing
well thank you Sam okay yeah I tried to
tell you last time but then I had a few
days to go but then I had to go to class
but here I am okay so I'm just a little
nervous what do you think the
coronavirus because the coronavirus
could kill tens of millions of people in
the world and like 6 million minimum
people if it gets out in the United
States what do you think it could hurt
the Trump voters who just believe that's
everything that everything wrong that
he's done is fake news
about everything wrong he can he cannot
do any wrong that he's infallible do you
think that like people dying around them
especially senior citizens which is
unfortunate could convince them well
you're getting its I don't know about
exactly the framing you're presenting
Sam but here's what I do think is true
and I've already sort of put down some
notes because I want to talk about this
on Monday if you believe Trump that
everything's fine and this is an
overblown hoax you're less likely to
take the steps that the CDC suggests to
protect yourself and thus you are more
likely to either get or spread
coronavirus and I don't want to call it
a Darwinian thing in any way but there's
something to if you believe it's a hoax
you won't protect yourself and therefore
you're more likely to get it or I guess
the idea that he has an under
conservative it wasn't like I met Trump
supporters are like yeah but he's
infallible and he's got it under control
and it's not going to come here yeah and
if it does come here it'll have it
anyway right well you know the good the
best news I've heard about this in the
last several weeks is that you know that
they were looking there many companies
are working on vaccines and it's
generally considered that it could take
9 to 24 months to get a working vaccine
for coronavirus to the public there is
an Israeli company that has a vaccine
already for the poultry version of
corona virus called ibv and they said
today that they've modified that vaccine
such that it could be ready for human
trials in weeks and potentially to
market in 90 days which if it's you know
it's very optimistic but if that's true
that really could be a game-changer and
who knows where we'll be in 90 days on
this thing yeah I think we could be like
exponentially worse in in 90 days it
might be too late in terms of people
buying and or getting into other
countries and hopefully not the US and I
have two video suggestions for you I
want you to do if you if you want do
your tastes on two topics okay it's long
and Ronald Reagan
as the first one I have exactly this tap
my mother's Irish Catholic but my
father's background is exactly the same
as yours like marrying Jewish okay yeah
but all if they only were in Argentina
there for like 50 years but like Eastern
Europe Argentina United States right and
so that's kind of funny that way I have
half the exact same background that you
do but I learned about Islam from like I
go to a campus of a bunker with a bunch
of different kids I'm like very
different backgrounds because I live in
Denver and I thought I'm gaining a very
very positive view on it and I want to
know what you think as someone you get
the idea I do Sam very good we will take
those suggestions under advisement it's
always great to hear from you okay a
wonderful day all right you too Sam
thank you so much let me do a couple of
other super chats let's see here
philosophy and critical thinking says
what are your thoughts on compulsory
voting I'm from Australia and we have
compulsory voting yeah there's
compulsory voting in Argentina as well
where I was born
I'm not that into the idea of making
voting compulsory in the United States
I'm into the idea of getting more people
to vote by making them understand the
importance of voting
that's my predilection so to speak I am
taking phone calls right now you can
call me right now at six one seven eight
three zero forty seven fifty I want to
say thanks to black white rook for
subscribing with for five months with
twitch Prime we are 27 twitch
subscribers away from our goal of 1200
which would be a delightful goal to get
to just for kicks because we got to our
initial goal of of 25 members let's make
the new goal at join pakman.com 50 just
for kicks just for kicks let's do
something risky I'm gonna pick up on a
call that is via Skype a lot of times
people calling in via Skype sometimes
it's just those people from other
countries sometimes it's trolls so let's
go to our one of our callers from Skype
what's going on hello you
that's you Oh fantastic hi David my name
is Stephen how are you doing good how
are you doing great good so I am in an
interesting position I am a progressive
thank you fair enough so I've been going
door to door talking to people trying to
get them engaged in local politics and
what I found is a really really
interesting divide between the younger
people who obviously are very much Pro
Bernie and the older generation but I
don't include in that about 20 years so
about somewhere between 35 to 55 there's
this group of people who are heads down
yep mouths shut you know och politics
you don't get involved in politics you
get to work you do your work you don't
get involved yeah and all these older
people who are frankly in and from the
activist generation that care yep
I'm trying to find a way to get them to
partner with the younger generation
because I feel like there's teamwork
that can happen there that can really
just like like cross mentorship help
them understand our current struggles
and at the same time teach a younger
generation how people mobilized in the
past and now is really bringing together
is the goal to bring them together in
support of a particular candidate or
just to bring them together to get a
little e active they bring them together
to find a common voice I know that
there's candidates I support and there's
candidates I don't and I don't want to
make this about that I want to make it
about trying to find a way to bridge
that gap so that people can have those
conversations locally between people in
these different generations what would
you suggest trying oh I I would you know
the problem is that very often even if
you find shared values very quickly you
will have differences of opinion
generationally about what are the
important issues and of course of what
are the righthand that it's to support
so I'd have to give that some thought
I've not thought about it in those terms
take your time thank you for taking my
call all right my pleasure
very good so let's see that was one
Skype call oh I just got disconnected
myself I accidentally that's the other
thing is when I take Skype calls I can't
tell which skype I'm on skype thank you
our calling into the day Ben and Joe
please do not use speakerphone Wow have
your question ready and listen for David
to call out your area code the number is
six one seven eight three zero forty
seven fifty and we are about to take
another call here for sure as soon as I
get back I got kicked off my own phone
system is that crazy it's really a
no-tolerance system even I can get
kicked off let's go to our caller from
the 907 area code whose calling today
from 907 which if I recall correctly is
that New York City nine one seven hello
nine one seven last opportunity if you
have muted yourself please unmute
yourself so that we can hear you all
right nine one seven is gone let's go to
the three one zero area code which I a
let's seize three one zero is Los
Angeles right yeah that is unlike how
are you I'm well this is Dylan I'm not
sure if you've ever covered this but I'm
curious if Bernie does win a plurality
of the votes yes become the Democratic
representatives and somehow via
super-delegates or some other means
someone else is nominated to be the
delegate right is there any world in
which he might pursue some other having
you to get on the to the presidential
election by a independent
nope I think Bernie knows that that
would hand the election to Trump and I
don't think you would do it okay yeah
all right David all right thank you very
much appreciate it
let's go next to our caller from the
2:07 area code 2:07 is is that the great
state of Maine does that mean yes it is
oh I'm sorry
awkward yes I am from Maine okay um okay
so obviously I watch your show and I
want to vote on Super Tuesday and
everything yep
um so recently some people in my college
came up to me and they started talking
to me about Lisa savage she's the Green
Party candidate and what I was wondering
um she's taking Susan Collins seat
or she's running for it okay got it got
it yeah and so Sarah Gideon she's the
Democratic one as well so I was
wondering would it be smarter for me to
use the rank-choice voting that we have
to try and vote for Lisa savage or go
with Sarah Gideon did you know yeah is
it Lisa savage or sausage savage Savage
okay I thought you said sausage the
second time listen here's the thing if
your politics are more aligned with hers
because of rank choice voting you can
vote for her but still not be helping
Susan Collins get reelected that's got
to be the priority right getting Susan
Collins out yeah that's what I wanted to
ask you about yeah yeah I mean so so the
whole point of rank choice voting is you
really want Collins out maybe you'd
prefer the green party person but my
guess is that you would rather the
Democratic candidate over Susan Collins
honestly I would rather bow for Susan
Collins exactly that's the whole point
or any choice that's the whole point of
it yeah okay I just wanted to know if it
was smarter to go for Lisa initially
thank you all right thank you very much
appreciate the phone call um let me say
thanks to Paul Carrell for subscribing
on YouTube at the soy boy level thank
you very much let's pick up a call let's
try a different nine one seven area code
if we can and call her from nine one
seven go ahead hmm
something seems wrong with 907 today
what's wrong with nine one seven that we
can't ever hear nine one seven it's
weird
all right let's try instead the six oh
five now six oh five is that for some
reason I'm thinking Milwaukee am i off
hi baby this is a visit Mario can you
hear me
yes I can't were you from high it's
actually a Sioux Falls South Dakota but
I actually moved from there I'm in
Washington state now okay well then I'll
out anyway uh yeah yeah so anyway um I
was wondering uh let's say that's like
Bernie does get the president he does
get a like the president and he does
legalize marijuana I'm in the military
so I mean um I'm just I'm just wondering
um do you think like if it is legally
like if it is federally like taken off
that list
you know how it's equal to hair and
whatnot schedule you think that
companies and yeah bite schedule one yet
you think that companies and then the
DoD would allow their workers to smoke
well I mean obviously not on the job but
like outside you know weekend but
holidays whatnot so just if you
reschedule cannabis from schedule one
that will not make it legal for
government employees if they're at an
agency that says no cannabis to use
cannabis obviously not when they're
working no it wouldn't I think that in
order for that to be considered there
would need to be certainly legalization
recreationally in the state in which you
work but because there are federal jobs
I think it would take even more than
that so I I would not I think that
there's a very long uphill battle before
that that would be allowed so even if it
was federally illegal
I mean legalize like completely you
don't recreationally mean DoD recen if
cannabis becomes recreationally
legalized federally then you can start
to have a conversation about whether
government government workers would be
allowed but that that were like very
many steps far from that right now
understood yeah all right my pleasure
great to hear from you let me say
welcome and thank you to Neptune
ninety-nine twitch I very much
appreciate that the twitch Prime
subscription also Alexa Cameron has
grabbed a youtube subscription and
nobody else has signed up at join
pakman.com
that's sad very very sad let's pick we
are taking calls at 6 1 7 8 3 0 47 50
let's pick up a caller from Skype Skype
caller what's your name where are you
calling from
hello yes that's you hello yes that's
you yes yes it is oh great it's good
so first Facebook for entering I hope
I'm not a pro so I basically I have two
questions about villages and I hope that
you'll be able to know did you say you
have two questions for virgins no no
about Buddha judge yes got it
yeah so I'm not an American and I'm not
sure if I'd had the vote if I'd
necessarily vote for him okay but I was
wondering he did it um I think a segment
about health care in Germany and their
model at the time and you know but it's
a pretty analytical guy and it's British
data-driven and if I'm not mistaken his
husband used to live in Germany also so
we should be aware of it at least to
some extent in my opinion and I'm
wondering if he is Medicare for all who
want it could be translated somehow this
be the America the German model because
the German model is basically you know
they Medicare for wanted you have the
the government-run one and you have all
the private ones that are regulated
there are basically you have the choice
oh yeah what what Buddha judge wants and
what Germany has seemed quite similar
are you saying is it possible you want
someone to notify Buddha judge of that
no I'm just wondering what do you think
about it because you know he's getting
all of crap about you know he's not
really about for Medicare it's not
really for making you know this kind of
effort so you need to vote for Bernie or
for one for it when in fact his model
might be actually very close to German
and might be actually more replaceable
and again I'm saying it as a person who
if I had the vote I would probably vote
probably any system that is less of a
change to the status quo is more likely
to become a reality but
no I don't think that's where you start
you start with really what you think of
as the ideal system the German system is
better than the u.s. system if you know
thinking ahead if you have to negotiate
to a system like the German system it's
much better than what we have now but
you know I'm more in line with the
Bernie healthcare idea than the Budaj
edge healthcare idea other family I
think we're on board with this one yep
I'm also wondering about this it's it
seems to me like it's almost assumed
that if there will be some kind of
contested convention that you know maybe
it's assumed that it if Bernie will get
a plurality both of the majority maybe
Warren will pitch in her delicate for
him and it's almost assumed that Buddha
judge will let's say pitch his delegate
for someone like you bite him do you
think he would necessarily be more
inclined to give his delegates to by
them than estándares in that again
because I'm not fully convinced it
doesn't seem that clear-cut to me you
know I am NOT a hundred percent on that
but my I think that what we should do is
we should table that discussion until we
at least get past Super Tuesday because
I think by midnight on Super Tuesday
we're going to know which of these
conversations we should be having I
think interesting well uh this one last
thing that just because you mentioned
before with another color that he said
on money and gonna talk about the corona
virus and they downplaying it etc I I'm
wondering if you've heard about what
happened in Korea that over they really
have a big problem there because there
was a cult that was actually religiously
downplaying the whole importance of
vaccinations and disease and everything
and that caused a huge uproar that I
think I believe they have even higher
growth in in cases and in China right
I'm looking at it right now today China
had four hundred and twenty eight new
cases and South Korea had nearly six
hundred new cases you're absolutely
correct my friend exactly yeah so I
guess my do relevant for your money
cause if you haven't looked into it yes
we'll look into that thank you very much
I appreciate the phone call and firm all
right thank you very much to hear from
you again let me say thank you to cookie
and Conrad thank you
let me say thank you to cookie Kombat
for subscribing with twitch Prime I
appreciate that I also want to say thank
you to gorge issue gorge issue is new
member number 31 today at join
pakman.com and Paul Carrell is new
member number 32 today at join
pakman.com over on utube Macarius 39
says David how can Warren justify a 15
million dollar super PAC only by saying
she needs it to win and then she would
cancel them I mean that that's basically
the lot you know she doesn't believe in
unilateral disarmament essentially Rock
Lee says caller is wrong
Germany equals multi-payer not public
option yes Germany is actually a multi
payer system that is absolutely correct
but it was irrelevant enough analogy I
would say let's get next to our caller
from the 303 area code I believe 303 is
303 Colorado yeah hey david azouz man
yes it is awesome yeah I'm originally
from Denver but I'm in Chicago now
beautiful I just graduated masters in
finance so I'm a finance guy and I so
I've always appreciated your economic
coverage I've always been impressed by
it
are you a finance guy or a finance bro I
wouldn't want to call myself a broker
okay
yeah I just enjoyed the subject and I'm
fascinated by it cool so you've been
talking about a lot about the stock
market drop recently and to me it just
seems like a very healthy response in
terms of like of a market such as price
in the risk that the global economy
faces right and and also given that like
most Americans don't like have stocks
someone like me who wants to build up
wealth like it's almost like watching
something you really want to buy just
get cheaper and cheaper in front of your
eyes right well so here's basically
here's my view and people who watch the
show know this I I dabble in some stock
trading I used to do a lot more of it
but basically now I only have six or
seven stocks I've talked about
they are Tesla and some others I'm
basically in in mutual funds and index
funds very low-cost index funds where I
might just pay five basis points a year
in fees right so I just ended up our
schedule twice a month I'm buying more
when the price goes down I get more
shares for my money and so if you
believe that this is just another one of
these adjust ins and eventually it will
recover nothing's wrong I I don't need
the money right now and it's worth less
but if I don't sell I'm not really
losing the money so everything's fine if
you believe that wonderful Corrections
is going to be the last one that takes
down at what some see is a completely
unsustainable economic system then we're
screwed but in that case we're kind of
screwed either way right no absolutely I
want one last quick question yeah I
noticed you've had bitcoiners on and
you've you actually accept that Bitcoin
on your website I'm like really
interested in crypto and especially
Bitcoin in general I was wondering if
when you get donations at Bitcoin if you
hold on to it or if you cash it out if
you're willing I know we haven't gotten
any Bitcoin anything for months and
months so typically what were we doing
we were I think cashing out half when we
were getting it but there hasn't been
any crypto contribution for a very long
time okay interesting yeah all right
thank you David all right great to hear
from you appreciate that let's see here
let's go to our caller from the 786 area
code caller from 786 what's going on
oh hello David hi I'm a big fan of yours
since like 2016 thank you even though we
have different news I still a fan okay
so my questions about the mmm piece like
theories of economics
yes modern monetary theory yeah I was
talking to my professor about it and I
asked him the same question I'm about to
ask you now even if the like let's say
the heterodox theory sub N and P are
correct
what are you buildings practical right
yeah heterodox theories of M and T are
correct wouldn't it still be impractical
such an impractical like series because
they
want Congress to be in charge of
inflation you know I don't know that
it's always the case that someone who
generally believes in the framework of
modern monetary theory wants Congress
making all of the decisions that that's
you'd have to do I mean than that I mean
I don't know because I'm reading because
I just want to learn I'm reading about
it and they want like Congress to to
like like let's say a control inflation
by by raising taxes when it gets too
high so listen my the framework of mmt
that I'm most familiar with is that
printing currency will not cause an
endless inflation spiral if it's being
printed for economically stimulative
programs I admit I'm less familiar with
that with the side of it that you're
discussing so I'd have to research more
to be able to comment intelligently oh
no worries about David you know I'm just
trying to do my research on my own and I
think that's a great thing to do
yeah I can I have one more question sure
I was like okay so I'm like a
libertarian and I was speaking to my
friends from like you know the lab and
I'm like telling them about how I think
Beauty judge will be the better person
to take on Donald Trump because it's
just such a like like a good debater
debater you'll like we my from my point
of view I think you will destroy Trump
oh because of how he like controls the
conversation during the debate and how
he how composed he is as a person like
wouldn't like what do you think about
that I am not convinced of that I think
that it's conceivable that Budaj edge
would get destroyed by Trump during a
debate I don't know that I buy that I
mean I just thought because I think that
like bridges justice more like like more
compost when you like comparing to
Bernie like Bernie they they make
firstly me like one of them because like
he wasn't standing up for himself like
with Warren and then he heard like those
like comments so he tried to like speak
louder and another in the next debates
so it kind of shows like less composure
where I think where the judge is just
like better
that I think Bernie Bernie has had some
pretty big kill shots on Budaj edge
during debates so by using the that
analysis I just don't think I agree with
you but I really appreciate the phone
call and I'm gonna move on because I've
got some people here that want to get on
let me say thank you to Operation Knope
for subscribing on Twitch with the
message my mom and sister switched from
Bernie to bloomie please send help
that's a hell of a situation that you're
dealing with my friend I don't know how
I would be able to intercede there let's
go next to our caller from the eight for
seven area code who's calling today from
eight four seven hi David I just wanted
to say that I really appreciate you
taking calls and your insights and
debates it's really interesting to hear
both I'm 18 near Chicago so I have a lot
of younger friends and what I found is
that a lot of younger people around my
area fall into three groups two of them
being conservative and progressive
activist okay and the other being
completely non engaged in politics to
the point where they don't even want to
go and vote right so my question is how
do you think I should go and reach out
to these people to encourage them to go
and vote the non voters
correct well what I find effective with
non voters is you know a lot of times
they say I'm not into politics okay
great I don't like politicians great
what do you care about unless they
literally have no interest whatsoever
they're gonna care about something that
relates directly to who they're electing
either at the state local or national
level so that's usually the best entry
point I mean now for example with
coronavirus a lot of people who are like
I don't care about politics they see
Trump completely incompetently lying
about coronavirus all of a sudden they
realize the importance of electing the
right people so oftentimes talk ask
people what it is that they do care
about when they say they're not into
politics okay
that's a great way of going around it
thank you all right mom I actually have
one more question that's not pertinent
what's your favorite book oh I mean I
couldn't tell you there's you'd have to
narrow it down to like a sub-genre I I
do read quite a bit and there's no way I
could tell it you know what the thing
what's your favorite song you know
okay well thank you very much David no
sub-genre you want to run by me
oh [ __ ] uh fantasy actually don't don't
read fantasy I don't like it alright
listen I you but check david pakman.com
slash recommendations i've got like a
hundred and fifty book recommendations
they're wonderful like you all right
check thank you by the way
so hassan [ __ ] is here in boston and
we've been chatting today trying to
figure out if we can meet up and he's
got this completely whacked out schedule
where he's like live streaming at PAX
East tomorrow he's going to the Bernie
rally which I'm gonna stay away from
just because it's just it's just chaos
you know it's a zoo and then he's like
planning to stream eight hours for the
South Carolina results so I don't even
know that we're gonna end up getting
together because it's um it's it's it's
just uh
it's crazy what Hassan has going on
let's see let's go next to our caller
from the two five six area code who's
calling today from two five six David
yes um hey this is um this is Gus from
Alabama hey Gus
so this is a coronavirus I sorta kind of
just want to run this by you and just
see what you have to say about this um
so so to to to quickly do quick things
my friend I want to hear the question
you're starting to sound like you're in
a room designed to echo if you just did
something where you stepped away from
the phone put it on speaker did
something try to undo it and then also I
was hearing my own voice back on a delay
so if you've got the stream up somewhere
please mute the stream hello oh boy I
think that click is the end of that
phone call that was weird okay if people
can clip for me the moment earlier where
I asked the German caller if he had
questions
for virgins if someone can clip that and
then email it to me I actually would
really appreciate that because I think
we're gonna want that for social for
next week let's try our caller from the
6-3 one area code who's calling today
from 631 hey pac-man Suzanne drew hey
Marie what's up
yes I got hey so I wanted to get your
opinion on um if you think Bernie should
include and like more like what how
capitalism plays a role in his policies
because I feel like maybe that would be
a good strategy going into like the
general because he's already called the
communist and a socialist and I think
right generally understand I don't know
that it's to his advantage to do that
necessarily it's an interesting idea I
just I'm not sure that he would really
benefit from it because I think a lot of
the people that support them already
understand the problems of the version
of capitalism that we have and then at
the same time I don't know that he's
gonna gain anything by talking more
about that I'm unsure it's a kind of a
question mark for me yeah yeah I just
didn't know like I wouldn't consider it
a pivot because capitalism does still
play a role under its policies obviously
yeah and I just thought maybe that would
like appeal to like the independence and
like the swing states right ya know I'm
not sure that it mean it's it I'm not
disagreeing with you necessarily it's
not my instinct of this would be
definitely good for them but it's an
interesting idea right right okay
okay thanks for taking my call all right
my pleasure great - great to hear from
you let's try our caller from the three
six one area code who's calling today
from three six one oh that me yes it is
oh this is well you know this is a dill
calling from Texas also known as uh
Dolan's or C attic on the superjet all
right thank you so much just calling it
I think it's my first question is offer
a few people bring up the coronavirus
and when I was going to ask those would
you see the coronavirus as something
that's really undermining the stock
market or is it just a catalyst knocking
down an already weakened state of
economy um III right so I've been saying
for a while that I believe there is
going to be a correction because just
one is due and there's always some other
correction coming up I think that
there's no question that coronavirus is
a catalyst now if it ends up not
becoming as bad as it could be and the
fundamentals of the economy don't change
I would expect the recovery if it is and
I think it's just too early to know if
it's if it's a catalyst for an already
weakened economy in some fundamental
level then I think we we will only know
that at some point in the future I think
anyone who claims to know that now is
just speculating all right I make sense
and I was wondering about your
perspective on a single-payer system
either allowing or not allowing
duplicative care what do you think is
the optimal position on that sorry
allowing what what did you say
duplicative care yes duplicative care do
you mean for the same patient and
procedure or do you just mean the
existence of people having private
insurance if they want it in addition to
Medicare for all
I mean allowing yet for modern private
insurance to cover the same procedures
that the public option does or the
public program not option well
you can't it's up to private insurance
to determine what they want to cover
that's the thing so the the thing about
the system is if Medicare for all were
to exist my approach would be you just
leave private insurance alone private
insurance can charge what they need to
charge on the basis of the size of the
risk pool that they have and if
everybody switches away to Medicare for
all that's going to make private
insurance more expensive because the
risk pool is going to become more
fragmented and the the market that they
claim takes care of things might
actually just do what it needs to do
with private insurance but I don't think
it's for the government to decide that
necessarily all right because I mean
there is a debate like I think when
Tulsi released her I don't think she
ever fully released a plan but she
talked about her Medicare choice or
single player plus or whatever she want
they call it yeah uh and in comparing
her what her plan was expected to be at
least with Bernie's plan like he he
allows supplemental care but like say
that Medicare for all covers a bone
marrow transplant or some other
procedure yep then under his bill that
can't be covered but under hers it could
yeah I don't want to hear why you outlaw
the coverage of that through private
insurance I know that there's this idea
of you get Medicare for all for all the
stuff that's medically necessary and
then you can get private insurance for
cosmetic or optional procedures but it's
like well those already aren't covered
by insurance so III just my instinct is
more to just set up the best system
possible don't worry about private
insurance let them do what they want to
do and if people migrate away from it
because it's inferior then private
insurance may go out of business or it
may only appeal to a certain portion of
the population but I I don't see any
reason to get so involved with private
insurance I would focus on just building
the best government-run system possible
yeah I wasn't I wasn't entirely sure of
myself if I had to think of an argument
I guess the idea is since private
insurance can pay the hospital's
whatever they want if we don't eliminate
duplicative care there's a risk that the
issue of rationing by wealth instead of
rushing by need would still exist if you
don't Bennett saying you have an
insurance opted to pay hospitals more in
that situation rather than less yeah
that the hospitals were then prioritize
people with insurance over people on the
public so the fact we need is what you
need to deal with legally rather than
the private insurance you say that the
hospitals would not be allowed to do
that but these are these are smaller
issues than the bigger picture of how
the system will function yeah but good
questions I appreciate them or I think
yep thanks for taking my call thank you
so much I appreciate it and on that note
I'm wrapping I've got to go out I've got
people waiting for me
very very anxiously here in the city of
Boston thanks to everybody who joined me
more streams shows